so Marvel's mutant God dies and it's
amazing check this out I'm really
excited to see how you guys how you guys
feel about this whole thing let's check
this out what this does here is this
initially opens up with Hope Summers and
exodus now here's the thing to
understand here by the time we get to
the end of this first little tidbit
we're gonna have to do a bit of an
explanation about Hope Summers to
understand why all of this matters but
what it does is it opens up with Hope
Summers and it opens up with Exodus the
two of them working side by side and
what ends up going on is they're
basically launching an attack of sorts
by effectively taking out any and
everybody who's considered to be
competition or effectively standing
against the power of the diamond
Sinister group right because remember
what's going on in sentence of sinister
is you effectively have a religious
Civil War that's really all this is
right you've got the diamond-headed
Sinister who all these folks like Hope
Summers initially served and then
ultimately defected from and then you
have the mother righteous right so the
versions of sinister with the hearts on
their heads basically all the night
crawlers is really all they are and then
you have storm and her Brotherhood of
evil mutants but everybody's just kind
of trying to live right and so what goes
on here is Hope Summers as she's given
to us is pretty dark and pretty Sinister
which is really interesting given the
nature of her character but what they do
is that by traveling around and
eradicating competition they ended up
targeting the combination of the cree
and the scroll Empires which have long
since been unified and that what they do
is that in this attack they blow up the
entire world now this is probably one of
the coolest things that Marvel's done
with regards to the X-Men that's why I
love this idea of creating different
mutants by merging different powers
together so what they have here is
what's called an l-bomb and an l-bomb as
it's described is a four gift Chimera
it's unstable so they're stored in a
tempest stasis Vault until they're
needed anyone with Lila Chaney's gift
can teleport to anywhere they've been in
the universe and when they get my
psychic imprint of the destination
they're good to go the l-bomb awry eyes
and the other three Gene payloads kick
in Firestar Leland and Micromax now
here's the benefit of this right so each
one of these people that we're talking
about here all have a very unique power
that when it's combined is just
catastrophic so Firestar is literally
just a walking nuclear reactor right
Leyland had the ability to manipulate
gravitational Mass those of you guys who
remember the old uh Phoenix Saga I'm
sorry the dark Phoenix Saga back in the
day when the X-Men confronted the
hellfire club and you had that guy who
was just kind of like he looked like a
really fat dude that's Leland right he
could manipulate the gravitational pull
of objects and make any member of the
X-Men or even all of them feel heavier
than they actually are and Micromax is
basically a mutant that has the powers
of Hank Pym right he can shrink and he
can grow by combining these things
together right nuclear fusion an
increase in gravity and growth and
shrinking what does that give you it
gives you a nuclear explosion on a
planetary scale big enough to wipe
without an entire world so quite
literally the l-bombs are the result of
the mutant population fusing Powers
together to create a nuclear bomb that
can not only detonate using the powers
of Firestar that's the whole basis
behind it but using the gravitational
powers of Leland can effectively
increase the gravitational mass of the
bomb but then with the power of Micromax
expand the explosion outward so it's
kind of nuts they basically created a
bomb that can blow up worlds and that's
what Hope Summers is doing she's just
traveling around the cosmos eradicating
entire worlds and wiping out whole
civilizations more so than that one of
the things that she talks about here at
least when she's having this
conversation with Exodus is she says I
don't clone well right only one of me at
once it seems Sinister said something
about it being a similar problem with
Gene now what she's referring to here
and this is one of those where if you
don't know the history of the X-Men it's
lost on you what she's talking about
here is Madeline Pryor so way back in
the day in the aftermath of the Phoenix
Saga and even partly leading up to the
Phoenix Saga that set a story come to
the realization that if Cyclops and Jean
Gray were to ever have a child that
child would be astronomically powerful
one of them was Rachel Summers who came
from Days of Future Past and eventually
became a host for the Phoenix and the
other is kind of cable but not really I
stay not really cable because the
attempt of sinister with cloning Jean
Gray came as being Madeleine Pryor but
she lacked all the powers of Gene but
the result was that when she and and
cyclops basically banged they ended up
producing cable and so effectively the
genetic potential of Gene and cyclops
came to bear when Cyclops and Madeleine
Pryor the clone of Gene ended up
procreating because cable is one of the
most powerful mutants to ever exist you
don't see it all that often because the
techno-organic virus is constantly
eating away at him but Strife is the
clone of cable and strife is a beast
this guy's an absolute Hoss right it's
nuts but it's one of those cool things
because she says my discarded bits can
synergize with all the duplicates of my
old crew and keep the resurrection
industrial complex ticking over true
Resurrection isn't quite as important
now that we've got the Clone that but
the Clones are not OG krakowa we're just
a superior method now here's the thing
to understand about Hope Summers and
this is when we kind of have to get into
a little bit of our history right this
is why she's so important here so wind
the clock back to the aftermath of House
of M and Marvel Comics right the Scarlet
Witch takes away 98 of the mutant
population's Powers at that point in
time there were only 198 mutants on
Earth and no New Mutants were being born
right that was basically it what ended
up happening is Marvel wrote a story
called Messiah complex which we have
covered and you'll find a link to it him
in the comment where we ended up finding
out that there was a girl that was born
in I want to say Anchorage Alaska I
can't remember off top my head but we
never found out a real name because her
parents were basically killed what ended
up happening is that it was a Mad Dash
by multiple groups William Striker and
his purifiers write the religious
Fanatics that want to kill Newtons they
were hunting after this little girl
Sinister and his Marauders were hunting
after this girl and so were the X-Men we
ended up finding out cable was was the
one that got to her ahead of time and
cable basically ended up rescuing this
girl but the cool thing is that Hope
Summers is the first mutant born since
the events of House of M the reason why
that matters is because she was kind of
like the Messiah because after Hope
Summers came along other mutants started
being born again and so for whatever
reason that almost follows a kind of
religious fervor people view her as the
mutant Messiah that's where she got that
name from but basically you ended up
learning that what Hope Summers can do
is copy the powers of any Mutant around
her and there is no upper limit so she's
astronomically powerful she can copy the
abilities of reality warpers Omega Level
telepath the whole nine yards there's no
cap there and so I want you to keep that
whole mutant Messiah a bit of history in
the back of your head because it'll
become important here in a minute but
one of the issues that they have is that
while they can't duplicate her her
ability to synergize the powers of
everybody that's on her crew that comes
from just her inherent abilities right
her inherent powers the problem with
this is that Sinister the red diamond
minister is still among their ranks and
what he reveals to them is what's called
Rasputin for which is basically the
perfect mutant that has been built by
Sinister using a multitude of powers now
the cool thing about Rasputin 4 is she
is arguably one of the most capable
mutants that we've ever seen in Marvel
Comics she's not all-powerful right the
nature of her character or at least the
nature of her abilities by having five
different powers planted inside of her
she has the osmia metal skin of Colossus
she's got the intangibility of kitty
Pride right she has the super strength
that comes with Colossus as well she's
got the force field of Unis the
Untouchable she has the healing factor
of x23 Laura Kinney and then she's got
the telepathy of Quentin choir so she is
wildly powerful right she's really
capable of what she can do and so it's
one of these moments where when she
displays her powers one of the things to
remember is that when we covered the
first issue of immoral X-Men the only
way the council would keep Sinister
alive is if he kept producing seeing
more and more powerful mutants for them
but in his statement to them about
Rasputin 4 what he says is this is it
right there's no possible way to give a
person six Powers this is the maximum
that I can possibly offer and in doing
so effectively seals his own fate he
basically tells them I can't do anything
more for that or more for you guys and
so in essence it's like well then he's
we have no more use for sinister anymore
this guy's gotta go and so Sinister
picks up on that relatively quickly what
he picks up on it pretty fast and comes
to this realization that his days are
numbered and it's only a matter of time
before they kill him off and so jump
back to Hope Summers alongside Exodus
now Hope Summers unlike her regular
counterpart right the one that came
before her this one is truly a clone and
because of that the kind of Messiah
Viewpoint that people have of her has
gone to her head she's become power
hungry and just sort of a warlord and so
going through and just eradicating all
these different races what ends up
happening is effectively her powers are
shut off and she's left for dead dead
right like she's been duplicating the
power of Exodus and Exodus has now shut
off her ability to access his powers and
he says like I am not with you you are
just a girl with a gun you are of no
more use to the counsel or your church I
am the church and the church is bigger
than you a messiah's purpose is to
inspire a church to pray that one day
they will return that a messiah is with
us diminishes them it makes true Faith
impossible for who could truly believe
in such a petulant childish girl you are
of more use to us dead than alive and he
basically leaves her there on that world
and she is ultimately killed by the
Satori forces that she's been trying to
wipe out now here's the here's a really
important thing about this this is why I
said I want you to keep that kind of
religious perspective of uh of of Hope
Summers in the back of your head when
the mutants started coming back into
existence as a result of seemingly the
birth of Hope Summers Exodus viewed her
as like her most loyal religious
follower he saw her as a messiah not a
God but as a messiah the second coming
of the mutant population and so he has
been loyal to her resolutely since she
first popped up on the scene and the two
of them encountered each other what's so
important about this is that despite him
saying things like you know the Messiah
needs to have a person that's prophesied
to return and yada the truth about it is
he has no more faith in her he doesn't
believe that she's the person she's
supposed to be and so leaving her for
dead right saying that you are more used
to us dead than you are alive basically
says that people are losing faith in you
they're losing faith in what your church
stands for but I will take over for that
I will preach the gospel I will make up
stories about how you perished and one
day you shall return for all of us and
lead us into a better future that kind
of a thing right so it's probably a mad
power grab but it's cool the funny thing
about this is that things are going to
go sideways for Exodus fast right now
following that you jump back over to
Sinister when he's having a conversation
with Rasputin and what he says here here
is in effect he screwed everything up he
even goes as far as telling her about
like krakowa right that in the early
days of krakowa when he sat on the quiet
Council and Krakow was first formed it
was a lush Garden it was a beautiful
place and in his Mad Dash for power and
his desire to control everything right
to conquer all existence that he set the
universe onto the path that it is now
because remember when it comes to sins
of sinister what he had secretly been
doing was planting his own influence or
his own kind of back door so to speak in
the minds of every single X-Men that was
resurrected so when the time came he
could seize control of them and he did
right for a time he had total control of
the X-Men and was leading a full-scale
conquering of the world but over time
the X-Men started to rebel against his
influence and the result is that they
ultimately turned on him leading him to
where he is now if he has no use they'd
kill him off and so if for no other
reason than self-preservation what he
does is he tells Rasputin 4 that their
mission now needs to be to quote unquote
fix the universe that he knows a way to
do it and he needs her help to achieve
it and she ultimately joins him now
what's so cool about this is that on
this Quest that they have to basically
reach this place in the universe where
they need to attain this kind of
artifact or this tool in order to save
everything that what they do is pass
through all these crazy and somewhat
wonky locations right these places that
are kind of dark and kind of screwed up
at the same time but it's really just
sort of the aftermath of everything
that's been going on because by the time
this third issue picks up 900 years have
passed remember sense of sinister takes
place in three phases all the number one
issues so immoral X-Men Nightcrawler
storm in the Brotherhood those are all
year 10. all the number twos are year
100 and all the number threes are year
one thousand so we're 900 years later
and they're no closer to finding this
artifact than they were when they first
started but what they end up doing is
coming across what's referred to as an
exodus world and that what ended up
happening is that following Exodus
basically taking out Hope Summers and
kind of rallying the entire religion
around himself things transpired exactly
as you thought they would it turned into
a religious Civil War that you ended up
having people who were basically
decrying the influence of Exodus and so
as opposed to Exodus being this singular
Uber powerful person that we know what
ended up happening is that by whatever
Manner and whatever means basically each
one of these Exodus worlds is their own
religious sect and that they have their
own version of Exodus that is their kind
of protector and so what happens is that
when Rasputin 4 gets to this world and
she's able to attain this artifact or at
least read the minds of the various
people who are here to find the location
of this artifact she accidentally wakes
up one of the Exodus now of course she
teleports away but in this Exodus making
its move and leaving the world what it
does is it violates the treaty among all
the Exodus worlds that all agreed you
stay away we stay away you stay on your
world we stay on our world and that's it
by basically violating it now now war is
on and so ultimately the entire Civil
War kicks off and all all these Exodus
armies and all these Exodus religions
start Waging War against each other now
we don't get to actually see how it
plays out which kind of sucks because be
honest with you guys Exodus is an Omega
Level telepath I would love to see how a
civil war among the religious groups led
by different versions of himself would
all end up coming into conflict with
each other and how it would turn out I
feel like that was a huge missed
opportunity maybe Marvel brings it back
at some point in the future but we end
up basically following Sinister and
Rasputin as they make their way forward
trying to locate this artifact as they
pass through different points in this
universe we learn different things Kitty
Pride for example is no longer the young
jovial fund member of the X-Men that we
grew up with reading Chris claremont's
run now she's literally a space pirate
just like traveling around the universe
and just wiping out entire groups like
pillaging and plundering and all that
kind of stuff we end up finding out that
at some point along the line Ileana
Rasputin the younger sister of Colossus
with the power to manipulate magic she
had tried to bring the Demonic realm of
limbo into the universe and was
unsuccessful but it left these kind of
holes right these sort of portals in all
these different places around the
universe and different versions of
Colossus all stand guard in front of
these portals annihilating anybody who
tries to enter it's kind of cool right
it's really really awesome the way this
whole thing has happened but once we
follow them to their destination they
end up finding the artifact the very
thing that they were looking for and
Sinister as he kind of talks to this
girl sort of Muses with himself and
saying like this is the thing that will
fix our problems and so when he sits
down and listens to it it's a message
from Destiny right now here's the thing
once we get to uh to oh my God night
crawlers right night crawlers number
three basically the conclusion of sins
of sinister you're gonna see just how
far reaching the Crea the pre-cognitive
abilities of Destiny are because she
basically set in motion events that were
guaranteed to have this one particular
outcome and it's because of this one
thing that the X-Men did at the very
beginning of sins of sinister her when
they shot the Juggernaut into space
because of that one thing it all comes
home to roost right it's one of the
coolest things one of the coolest
moments in sins of sinister right but
literally in her message to to Nathaniel
Essex right the Sinister she says I
stole your lab with storm Stellaris and
the Iraqi if you're listening to this
they will have hidden it again when I
tried to reset the universe this will be
because Raven is dead and if Raven is
dead oh God I hate myself she would hate
me for this Nathaniel if you get back
your moras and you return to the Past
come to me I will join you now remember
just kind of reiterate here the mermaid
taggers right Mormon Tigers power is
that whenever she dies the universe
resets and so when storm and the
Brotherhood realized that was the case
they stole the moiras from Mr Sinister
so we couldn't kill one reset the
universe giving himself all the
information he needs to know to
understand how to ensure that he
succeeds this time around right to like
keep things out of being a vicious cycle
so it's kind of a cool moment because
she says yes I fought you I didn't trust
you with your plans and I also know it
is impossible for you to trust anyone
but you must try now I am trying to find
a way to save Mystique I see the future
and there is only death for her it's
horrible to see the woman you love torn
asunder so many times I know you can't
understand your nightmare Dimension was
the longest path of her life so I
followed it she beat the odds so many
times and I tried to be hopeful no world
is truly a hell with her in it now if
she's gone again we must try again and
perhaps I can discern another route
alongside yours it's a really cool
moment because again this recording
comes from one before Destiny died and
two before the death of Mystique but
remember the only thing Destiny cares
about the only thing that matters to her
is that her and Mystique have a life
together that's it right she would let
the world burn she'd let the universe
set on fire if it means that her and
Mystique could find a way to live a life
together but once Mystique is dead the
response of Destiny is then all bets are
off right if allying myself with
Sinister and telling him where the
mortars are so he can kill one and then
reset everything if that's the price
that needs to be paid in order for
myself and Mystique to have a life
together then I will Doom a universe to
do it right so it's really cool the way
this happens and so what she says is she
says one more thing I know your eventual
goal is to transcend time and space to
become a Dominion you do not succeed I
know you'll think I'm trying to trick
you but this is your only hope Nathaniel
give up now that's one of the things to
keep in mind and this all went back to
Jonathan Hickman's initial run on the
X-Men house and powers of x if you guys
recall during that story we had what
were called the post-humans basically
this idea that Humanity kind of merges
itself with a cybernetic organism right
they like Humanity becomes cyborgs and
then at a future point in time the
Phalanx would show up to Earth having
traveled to so many different worlds and
if they deem that world technologically
advanced enough it merges with the
phalanes that's what the post-humanity
landscape was looking for which of
course would lead to the eradication of
the entirety of the mutant population
Sinister wanted to beat him to the punch
right he wanted to attain this
absolutely you know this astronomical
level of power for himself and so that's
always been his goal but her telling him
you will not achieve your goal you will
not get to where you're looking for then
the only real option Sinister has is to
say okay fine then we have to wipe out
we have to kill one of the mores and
reset the universe because Destiny's
precognitive abilities are not to be
defied and even Sinister himself despite
his vanity despite his level of power
despite his lust for absolute power even
he knows better than to question what
Destiny tells him and so when this
conversation or really this kind of
message between Destiny and Sinister
ends that's when Rasputin 4 shows up and
realizes that Sinister is not going to
save the universe he's going to kill one
of the marors and wipe it out and her
desire to continue living runs in direct
conflict with that now this is one of
the things that I love about this
because if this story was written in
like 1995 right then she would have said
well then let's find a way to reset
everything but let's make sure that I
get back to the main Marvel Universe and
they would have just rolled her over
into the main Marvel Universe and she
would have just had a role or
established a role for herself going
forward here it's nope we're gonna blink
this universe out and if you happen to
make it through that's cool but at the
end of the day like she's fighting for
her own Survival as opposed to allying
with Sinister and then trying to find a
way a way to make it out alive now
what's really interesting about this is
Sinister literally tells her I gave you
a whole host of abilities I made you the
perfect recipe or the perfect Chimera
right you've got like five different
powers and he says but there's one power
that I never gave you that's the power
of flight and so he literally Jetta
sends her out of the airlock like he
shoots her out of the airlock and she's
just stranded in space she'll survive
but she's just stuck out in space just
floating out there seemingly for
eternity and then Sinister continues on
his mission where he ultimately ends up
traveling to what is by all standards
the measurement Earth now here's the
cool thing about this it doesn't look
like Earth it looks like a giant fungal
kind of thing there's a reason for that
and that's actually covered in
nightcrawlers it's a result of a guy
named Dr Nemesis who's basically merged
with all the fungi Across the Universe
and has just kind of turned everything
into fungus it's weird it's wonky but
when Sinister gets there he encounters
two people one of whom is a doom bot and
the second is a robot version of Maura
McTaggart it's why he doesn't just kill
around the spot and then reset
everything but what he tells her is our
mission here our goal is to find a way
in to basically find these moras that
were taken by storm and her Brotherhood
kill one reset everything and call it a
day and this robot Mora is perfectly
fine with it she's like yep that's
exactly what we need to do more so than
that a thousand years in the future Emma
Frost with her traditional Diamond form
she's no longer in her Diamond form I
mean she has it but she doesn't use it
instead what ended up happening is she
merged with a portion of the Crimson Gem
of sidorak so she seemingly is kind of
like an Earthly avatar for sidorak the
Demonic entity itself but she has this
sitarak diamond former the sidorax stone
form it's cool because seemingly her
level of power is astronomical more so
than that she's informed by Beast who
again under control a Sinister that
Sinister himself is still alive because
they believed he had died right in this
900 year period when he had just
disappeared with Rasputin 4. they
assumed he had just been killed and
whether it was due to their hubris or
just the fact that they didn't really
need him anymore they never had a reason
to go looking they just didn't really
care whether or not he was there because
they never took him seriously enough to
be any measure of a credible threat and
so what ends up happening is jumping
back with Sinister he travels back to
the base of storm and the Brotherhood of
mutants who basically have been
operating without storm seemingly ever
since she died and of course he's met by
John ironfire who was the second in
command to storm the problem is that of
course iron fire is a lot older than he
used to be and in this conversation with
sinister Sinister literally says I'm
trying to find the moras and all that
kind of good stuff but before we
actually find out what happens there we
jump back to Rasputin for her to be met
with a telepathic communication where a
person pleads with her cage right they
literally tell her I understand where
you're coming from you seem to have
gotten yourself in a pickle you have
been played poorly my sweet thing the
man who did you dirty is running here
and there free and all naughty I should
ask you what you most regret but it's
written all over your shiny face you
regret trusting him do you want revenge
and the response of Rasputin is more
than anything and the person says good
then the real question is do you want to
make a deal and so seemingly everybody's
gunning after Sinister now and all this
is going to come to a head in the final
part of this whole Arc which is amazing
because what's going to blow your minds
in the video that we get to when we
cover the nightcrawlers we're gonna see
Galactus with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I'll catch you
all later
peace